Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In many previous episodes, we talked about
generative adversarial networks, a recent
new line in machine learning research with
some absolutely fantastic results in a variety
of areas.
They can synthesize new images of animals,
create 3d models from photos, or dream up
new products based on our edits of an image.
A generative adversarial network means that
we have two neural networks battling each
other in an arms race.
The generator network tries to create more
and more realistic images, and these are passed
to the discriminator network which tries to
learn the difference between real photographs
and fake, forged images.
During this process, the two neural networks
learn and improve together until they become
experts at their own craft.
And as you can see, the results are fantastic.
However, training these networks against each
other is anything but roses and sunshine.
We don't know if the process converges or
if we reach Nash equilibrium.
Nash equilibrium is a state where both actors
believe they have found an optimal strategy
while taking into account the other actor's
possible decisions, and neither of them have
interest in changing their strategy.
This is a classical scenario in game theory
where two convicted criminals are pondering
whether they should snitch on each other without
knowing how the other decided to act.
If you wish to hear more about the Nash-equilibrium,
I've a put a link to Khan Academy's video
in the description, make sure to check it
out, you'll love it!
I find it highly exciting that there are parallels
in AI and game theory, however, the even cooler
thing is that here, we try to build a system
where we don't have to deal with such a situation.
This is called Generative Latent Optimization,
GLO in short and it is about introducing tricks
to do this by only using a generator network.
If you have ever read up on font design, you
know that it is a highly complex field.
However, if we'd like to create a new font
type, what we're typically interested in is
only a few features, like how curvy they are,
or whether we're dealing with a serif kind
of font, and simple descriptions like that.
The same principle can be applied to human
faces, animals, and most topics you can imagine.
This means that there are many complex concepts
that contain a ton of information, most of
which can be captured by a simple description
with only a few features.
This is done by projecting this high-dimensional
data onto a low-dimensional latent space.
This latent space helps eliminating adversarial
optimization, which makes this system much
easier to train, and the main selling point
is that it still retains the attractive properties
of generative adversarial networks.
This means that it can synthesize new samples
from the learned dataset.
If it had learned the concept of birds, it
will be able to synthesize new bird species.
It can perform continuous interpolation between
data points.
This means that for instance, we can produce
intermediate states between two chosen furniture
types or light fixtures.
It is also able to perform simple arithmetic
operations between any number of data points.
For instance, if A is males with sunglasses,
B are males without sunglasses, and C are
females, then A-B+C is going to generate females
in sunglasses.
It can also do super resolution and much,
much more, make sure to have a look at the
paper in the video description.
Now, before we go, we shall address the elephant
in the room: these images are tiny.
Our seasoned Fellow Scholars know that for
generative adversarial networks, there are
plenty of works on how to synthesize high
resolution images with more details.
This means that this is a piece of work that
opens up exciting new horizons, but it is
not to be measured against the tenth followup
work on top of a more established line of
research.
Two Minute Papers will be here for you to
keep you updated on the progress, which is,
as we know, staggeringly quick in machine
learning research.
Don't forget to subscribe and click the bell
icon to never miss an episode.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!